Jean-Luc
Mélenchon avez-vous le sentiment parfois
de vous être laissé griser par vos
paroles danger
ous
[Musique]
citoyenne c'est pas que j'ai été grisé
c'est que tout d'un coup j'ai été
débordé par ce que je ressentais on
n'est pas des voyous on n'est pas des
bandit
bon cet homme me menace de son arme il
me dit monsieur je suis armé c'est
ridicule je sais bien mais je suis
rempli d'une indignation parce que la
République c'est moi c'est pas lui je
suis le bruit et la fureur c'est un
verre de Shakespeare qui vous est lisez
un de ces trois là vous allez cracher du
sang le roi Louis XI qui était un sommet
de la bilité de l'intelligence politique
dit à un moment donné ma langue m'a
coûté cher je peux dire que la mienne
aussi